[MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
JEREMY HYLTON: So I
just finished the book
over the weekend, and I really
appreciated all the stories.
You have been
firsthand participant
and talked to lots
of other people
who are about the evolution
of this from a crazy idea
that a handful of
small teams worked on.
And so I really
loved all the stories
and just getting to know
the peoples, someone
you might hear
about in the news.
And I just loved the way
you told the stories.
So I thought since this
is-- we're at Google--
this is a book about
the driverless car,
maybe a fun story
to jump into would
be to tell everybody a
little about your first ride
in a chauffeur car.
LAWRENCE D. BURNS: Yeah,
I'm happy to do that.
And thanks, everybody,
for coming today.
It's a real pleasure.
It's a pleasure to be part
of your team actually.
I was at General
Motors until 2009.
We had competed in the DARPA
Urban Challenge in 2007.
That was a race of robotic
cars, and the first prize
was $2 million dollars.
And GM was starting to
hit the wall at that time,
so I figured we
needed the money.
We better go out
and win this race.
[LAUGHING]
But we sponsored
Carnegie Mellon's team
and Chris Urmson, who
subsequently led this program
for Google self-driving
cars, reached out to me
after I left GM.
They were looking for a
gray-beard auto executive
that could help them out.
So I came out in 2010.
The deal was I'd come
out and talk to them
if I could ride in the car.
And they had 13 Priuses, and
it was remarkable progress.
Because at the
Urban Challenge, we
had a Chevy Tahoe sport
utility vehicle that
was just loaded with hardware.
You could barely squeeze
one person into the vehicle.
And by the time they were doing
the testing in 2009 and '10,
they had it in a Prius.
Most of all the hardware
was in the trunk
of the Prius plus the
sensors on the outside.
So at that time could ride
on 101 in the vehicle.
And it's basically
an Expressway.
So I drove the car out.
I had a technician next to
me in the passenger seat,
and I had an engineer
in the back seat,
and I had a big red panic
button on the console.
So this is late
2010, early 2011,
and they said,
OK, just engage it
like you would cruise control.
I was in the middle
lane of the freeway,
and my hands are shaking
over the steering wheel.
My feet are shaking.
I'm thinking this is crazy.
But once I engaged it
within about a couple
of minutes, Jeremy, it
started feeling natural.
The car was intuitive even
at that point in time.
A Volkswagen Beetle
came up on my left
and cut it in front of me, and
I realized the car I was in
had already backed
off and started
to create a gap for that
vehicle to get into.
And you would never be able
to do that as a driver.
This technology is like
eagle-eye vision with eyes
in the back of your head.
Later on, a big semi
truck came up on my right,
and sure enough my car
was nudging over a bit.
But what I found so fascinating
was after the first 10 minutes,
I was so relaxed, I
was even worried about
whether traffic backed
up in front of me.
I never thought about
jumping to the right lane
or left lane to get
in front of someone.
It just took all the road rage
and stress out of driving.
So I was sold.
And that was a remarkable
accomplishment and just
a real testament to how good
this team was that you had
at Google self-driving cars.
JEREMY HYLTON: Yeah, it was
really striking to hear the--
there's a story you
tell about I think
riding in one of the early
Carnegie Mellon cars.
LAWRENCE D. BURNS:
Yeah, well, I--
because General Motors was the
sponsor of the Carnegie Mellon
boss--
we call the boss
La Chevy Tahoe--
I thought it was
important that I--
being head of R&D--
go out and put in an appearance
and get to know the team.
We had some of our engineers
embedded with the team.
And so I went out,
and they handed out
on their test track,
which was a real old steel
plant that had been--
they just grabbed it
and started using.
I don't know if they
had permission to do it,
but it was rutted
roads and everything.
And they were showing
me how the vehicle
would operate autonomously.
And I said I'd
like a ride in it.
And they looked
at me and smiled.
They didn't say no, but
I said, yeah, I really
would like to ride in it.
So they squeeze me in that one
area that you could fit into.
Well, this vehicle wasn't
designed for a human.
This vehicle was designed
to run a self-driving car.
So it accelerated very
aggressively, stopped very
aggressively, cornered
very aggressively.
And within about 30 seconds,
I'm getting so carsick,
and they're all laughing
about this because they really
put one over on me.
But that was an important point.
The Carnegie Mellon
team felt that by being
an aggressive driver, we were
more like an X Games athlete
in this competition.
We knew Stanford was going to
be more like figure skater.
And they were going to have a
really smooth, nice, precise
vehicle.
But we knew enough
about the race
that we thought we could pick
up six minutes by accelerating
hard and braking hard.
And we won the
race by 20 minutes,
so that was an important
part of our car.
JEREMY HYLTON: Yeah.
Yeah.
You mentioned riding in the
chauffeur car the first time.
You pretty quickly were relaxed
and not worried about things.
Then you comment
that there actually--
they're different
strategies being
pursued in the marketplace
today about how do we
deploy this technology, how do
we bring it to a mass audience?
And one is this
driver-assist version,
and the other is
more of a service.
And you observe that--
what did you say?
I think that the
driver-assist version
says you don't need to
pay attention to the road.
Except that because
it's an assistant,
it also says you need to be
paying attention at all times
in order to take over.
And I wonder if
you want to comment
a little bit about that.
LAWRENCE D. BURNS: The
Google the self-driving car
team I think made two
really big decisions.
They made a lot of great
decisions, but early on they
made the decision
that they wanted
to create a car that
didn't rely on what's
called vehicle-to-vehicle
or vehicle-to-infrastructure
communication.
So a lot of people
on this field thought
that if you get cars
talking to each other,
they could avoid each other.
But I think the Google
self-driving car
team realized that you'd
have to have all cars capable
and would take forever
to get to that point.
They also believe because
of your background mapping
and because of their knowledge
of the sensors that they
could actually do a
standalone self-driving car.
And that was
critically important.
They began to develop this
technology that I experienced
on the freeway, and
they thought maybe
they could do an initial
product called a highway assist.
And they did a dog
fooding exercise
with the local Mountain
View Google employees,
asked them to use the
vehicle on weekends.
They had to promise to pay
attention to their driving,
but they could take it
to Lake Tahoe and stuff.
Well, lo and behold,
within the first few weeks,
we realized that these people
were totally distracted.
One individual even fell asleep.
And you would never have
been able to re-engage them
if something came up.
And Nathaniel
Fairfield on a team,
he reached an
important conclusion
I think shared with all of us.
He said, if we always keep
the driver in the loop,
we're never going to be
safer than the driver.
Ninety percent of the crashes
are due to human error,
so they concluded these
driver assist, Jeremy, was not
consistent with
their goal, which
was to eliminate car
crashes all together
and made the second
really important decision
their commitment was
to totally autonomous
where a person would never
be asked to take over.
Now you can imagine
what a challenge that
is because you have to discover
all those really unusual things
that happen in everyday
driving or every year
driving, the long
tail, and that's
part of what's going on right
now is it's continued learning.
But it's also part of the
reason why Waymo has such a head
start on everyone
because they've
been doing this a long time.
And they've accumulated
a lot of experience.
JEREMY HYLTON: I was curious
as far as reducing the fatality
rate, I checked.
It sounds like there's
a little over one
fatality per 100 million
miles driven or something.
So to get a sense on
whether really safer,
does that mean we need to get
a few hundred million miles
driven with these cars?
LAWRENCE D. BURNS:
You have to or--
and-- I would say
and supplement that
with AI and machine learning
and great simulation models.
So this isn't about
any one sensor.
It's not about any one
enabling technology.
It's this combination of maps,
sensors, onboard processor
software, and then in
the development process
to be able to go out there
and capture a lot of data
when you encounter something
unusual on the road,
bring that back to the
lab and simulate it--
virtually simulate it in reality
and learn about the edge cases
and get confident
that you've dealt
not just with the unusual
thing that you observe.
So take traffic
circles, for example.
We've all-- you've all probably
been in a traffic circle.
Have you been in two lane
traffic circles or three lane
traffic circles?
And you have to
capture everything
about all of those
in the real world
or can you model that
and get to the edge cases
and move yourself forward?
JEREMY HYLTON: Yeah, I
hadn't thought about that.
So part of it is
real world driving.
Part of it is taking
the data you've
collected from those
drives and simulating.
And that gets us closer
to those 100 millions.
LAWRENCE D. BURNS: So
you say why might Google
get into this because
we're not a car
company but extraordinary deep
knowledge of computer science
and robotics, the best
servers in the world,
the best mapping system in
the world, great AI teams.
And it's really a
fundamental shift
in what are the core
competencies required
to be a leader in
transportation in the future
versus the historic ones.
And the historic
ones, which we covered
quite a bit in the book,
really 130 years of history
of combustion-based
vehicles that
are energized by
oil, that are human
controlled with the controls
being hydraulic, and electronic
primarily.
And those competencies were
about combustion and the driver
interface to get the
ultimate driving machine.
And we're going to have in
the future the ultimate riding
machines, not the
ultimate driving machines.
So this is a profound shift in
the fundamental competencies
to be a leader in
transportation.
JEREMY HYLTON: Yeah,
I think you explain
that there are three trends
that are coming together.
There's the software and
the driverless technology.
And there is electric
vehicles, which
have some advantages
like they're
much easier for
software to control
than an all-mechanical one.
And then there's this idea of
transportation as a service
rather than personal ownership.
And those are like
the three factors
that are all coming together.
LAWRENCE D. BURNS: Yeah.
Yeah, they've all come together.
Two of them are really
technology enabled,
and the other one is a
business model innovation.
So, again, it's not
about one thing.
It's about several things
combining at the same time.
I like to call that
the power of and.
That's the connecting
of the dots.
And here's how this logic goes.
When you have an
autonomous vehicle,
suddenly you don't need to pay
a person to drive the vehicle
and reposition it.
And that makes
selling transportation
as a service a pretty compelling
opportunity because you've
lowered the cost then of
getting high utilization out
of a vehicle.
So it can pick me up,
take me to my destination,
drop me off, and then,
without any labor costs,
go a couple of blocks and
pick you up and take you
to your destination and
drop you off and keep
doing that throughout the day.
And you get very high
utilization of that fleet.
Today most cars are used
about 12,000 miles a year.
These transportation
service business models
suggest it'll be
75,000 miles a year.
The cars are parked
90% to 95% of the time.
What I just described means the
vehicle is en route to pick you
up rather than being parked.
But what you do then is,
because it's autonomous
and it's a service, you want
to optimize the cost per mile.
The car industry
has been focused
on optimizing the
price of a new car
at a dealership when you go
there and fall in love with it
to buy it.
When you optimize
the cost per mile,
it turns out electric drive
is a really good deal.
Because a fleet
optimized cost for mile,
you want the vehicle to
last about 300,000 miles.
An electric drive can save
you $0.05 to $0.10 a mile.
That's $15,000 to $30,000
over the lifetime,
which is more than enough to
pay for the electric drive.
So the funny thing about this
is it's autonomous vehicles
I think that's going to
get us past the tipping
point for electric vehicles.
Now to make the
story even better,
80% of the trips we make as
Americans are one and two
person trips, but our cars
and trucks are designed-- way
overdesigned-- for
the occasional trip.
When you tailor design this
autonomous electric vehicle
for this transportation service
and the most typical trips,
it probably wants to be
a two-person vehicle.
It's probably going to have
about 1/10 as many parts in it
as a conventional car, and
that is really important
to understand if you're
in the car industry.
So it's the simplicity
of electric drive.
You don't have transmissions.
You don't have exhaust systems.
You have gasoline tanks.
You don't have all
those mechanical parts
in the engine moving.
And you get rid of all the
parts with a driver interface.
So boom, it's really
transformational.
JEREMY HYLTON:
One of the stories
that actually was one of my
favorite in the book I think
it was when Byron McCormick
brought you out to the vehicle
assessment center.
And he showed you--
maybe you want to describe
what that was like.
LAWRENCE D. BURNS: Yeah.
In 1988, I was asked to lead
an initiative at GM called
Design for Manufacturing.
And we had a lot of
different products,
and our cars just seemed
like they were harder to put
together than our competitors'.
And so we decided to tear
apart our competitors' cars,
lay out all the parts,
and then conceive of how
they're building their cars.
And lo and behold, we
were way uncompetitive.
So this teardown center
became an important place
for a lot of the
leaders at GM to begin
to visualize what was going on.
Byron McCormick,
who reported to me,
was one of the
best technologists
I've ever worked with.
He ran the battery
plant for GMZV1.
He was one of the
pioneers of what's
now called stability control.
But very importantly, he led
our fuel cell program as well.
And Byron and his
team conceived of what
we call a vehicle platform
called e-flex, which
was based on these principles of
electric motors in the wheels,
energy storage in the platform,
almost like a skateboard,
and then by wire steering,
by wire breaking,
and really optimized
route software.
And when he had them-- a
prototype done and laid
out all the parts
in a torn down way,
in the same place where he
took apart a Chevy Malibu,
he took about a Prius
and laid those parts out.
Well, the Prius had
more parts than Malibu
because it was a hybrid.
But the e-flex had
radically fewer.
You could really see
where the industry was
going to head when it was
going to be an electrical
and electronically controlled.
So we brought my
boss Rick Wagner in,
who is the chairman
and CEO of GM.
He had to see this,
and he got it.
He understood it wasn't
just all the fewer parts
because the parts that you have
to design, engineer, release,
manufacture, tool, they
drive the cost structure
of a car company.
But it also was the software,
and that was just so important.
And I think a lesson out of
that is when you have an idea
and you're trying
to communicate it,
getting to rapid
prototyping and making
it visible for a lot of
people I think really
helps get your
idea communicated.
JEREMY HYLTON: Yeah.
Yeah, I love the visual
of seeing the car exploded
and all the parts of the Malibu
and then the electric vehicle
with radically fewer parts.
Just a great way to
get your point across.
One of the things
I found fascinating
was that it sounds
like maybe 2010, 2011,
I think you were at
Columbia, and you were
modeling how this would work.
I think you picked Ann
Arbor and a few other cities
and found that you can offer
this service with actually not
that many cars relative
to the number of cars
that people actually park in
their driveways in Ann Arbor.
LAWRENCE D. BURNS: Yeah,
there was a famous economics
professor at Columbia
named Jeff Sachs,
and he had written the
book, "End of Poverty,"
and he was running an Institute
called the Earth Institute.
And when GM was going bankrupt,
he came and visited us,
and I gave him an overview
of some of the thinking we
had longer term.
And Jeff and I hit it
off, and when I left GM,
he asked me if I would
lead Columbia's program
for a sustainable mobility,
which I decided to do.
And what we were really
interested in is--
no kidding-- what
would a city look
like if you combined
tailor-designed vehicles
for the two-person,
one-person trip
with electric drive that are
autonomous and partly shared.
How many would you need to
meet all the transportation
requirements of a city,
and how much would it cost?
So we decided to model this.
And at that time there was
a really neat database--
it was a 2009
household travel survey
from the federal government.
And it gave us a good
idea of how many cars
were in cities like Ann Arbor,
Austin, or Columbus, Ohio,
Rochester, New York, Manhattan,
Palm Beach County, Florida.
So we sat down and
started to model this.
And there were 200,000
cars in Ann Arbor.
About 120,000 of them stayed
within the metropolitan area.
And our modeling
came back and said
we could get all of the
trips that those cars are
making done with 50--
18,000 shared vehicles, just
15% of the cars that were there.
We thought we had to be wrong
because at the same time
we concluded we could
get to the customers
quickly within minutes
and that the fleet would
be highly utilized.
And we kept studying
this, convinced we
didn't have it right.
But finally we understood the
population density of places
like Ann Arbor was high
enough such that the trip
frequency throughout the
14 busy hours of the day
was high enough such that
just after they dropped me
off somewhere in Ann
Arbor, sure enough,
there was a high probability
someone a couple of blocks
away was requesting a ride.
And that's how the
math worked out,
and that was the moment and
then when we said what was this
cost, the electricity
cost, the insurance,
the cost of the vehicle being
depreciated, finance costs,
both your time costs
and out-of-pocket costs,
we thought we could get
something on the order of $0.20
a mile.
And that's compared to owning
and operating a car at about
$1.50 including your time cost.
So you bounce that against
the 3 trillion miles a year
that Americans drive, and
that's a $4 trillion disruption.
And that that was
a pretty big a ha.
We went about getting this story
told, and it was lot of fun.
JEREMY HYLTON: Yeah.
Yeah, and so how much
of that $4.5 trillion
is spent on fossil fuels?
LAWRENCE D. BURNS: Well, we
use about 180 billion gallons
of gasoline a year, so $3
I'd say about $500 billion.
JEREMY HYLTON: So
if this works out,
it's going to really
significantly changed the
[INAUDIBLE]
LAWRENCE D. BURNS:
Very significantly.
And an interesting
irony is-- sad irony
about that is the year
General Motors went bankrupt,
embarrassingly we
lost $32 billion.
Exxon Mobil made $45 billion.
That year, oil prices had
gone to $1.60 a barrel.
I'm sorry, $160 a barrel.
You count 160, and
they make $45 billion.
That was the highest
profit ever made
by a company at
that point in time.
And the sad thing about
that oil consumption
is when you refine
it to make gasoline
and you burn it in a
combustion engine, about 75%
of that energy is--
let's say 75% to 80%--
it gets lost as heat
and friction and sound,
that kind of a thing.
So about 20% to
30% creates torque.
That turns the
wheels of the car.
The cars weigh 3,000
to 4,000 pounds,
and people weigh
120 to 200 pounds.
Jeremy, the bottom
line is just 1% or 2%
of the energy in that gallon of
gasoline moves you the driver.
And here's this company that
makes $45 billion dollars,
and the only way
ExxonMobil could
have done that is because GM
was in the business of building
and selling cars
that relied on oil.
JEREMY HYLTON: Yeah, so it's
a disruption in a lot of ways.
LAWRENCE D. BURNS: Well,
it's a huge disruption.
It's a disruption to the
people who drive for a living.
I understand that,
and I respect that.
If my profession was
being disrupted by this,
I don't think I would feel
comfortable about that.
But also it's a disruption
to the auto industry
because far fewer parts mean far
fewer employees in the supply
base and at the original
equipment manufacturing
base but also far fewer
engineers because you
have to design fewer parts.
It's a disruption to the
corner gas station operator
because these vehicles
will be supplied probably
through fleets.
By the way, you can have
one for your dedicated use.
Please don't think
the only solution here
is a shared vehicle like
an Uber without a driver.
You certainly can
subscribe to one
and have it for your own
personal dispatch desires.
But at the end of
the day, you're
not going to want to stop to
refuel that or recharge it.
So this recharging's going
to be done at a depot,
not at a corner gas station.
The beauty of that is it lets
us introduce alternatives to oil
without having to have
170,000 gas stations.
So you pull that string,
parking gets impacted,
dealers get impacted, land use
and real estate gets impacted,
the entire economy gets
impacted quite frankly.
JEREMY HYLTON: It was
fascinating to enter
into that analysis in the book.
I was also thinking we're
here in New York City.
So I think the recent news is
that the city is considering
putting a limit on the number
of Uber and Lyft drivers.
And I wonder what your
take on that policy
issue in the short term is.
LAWRENCE D. BURNS:
Well, I believe
it's an important issue because
you have an awful lot of people
out there trying to make
money as an Uber driver.
And there needs to be this
balance between supply
and demand.
And if you have too many
people out there and not
enough customers, you're going
to have more cars on the road
not really creating value.
So that's problematic.
I do worry about
governments thinking
they can regulate that
rather than the market,
finding that right balance.
So I am concerned about that.
When you do get to
driverless cars,
your whole goal will be to
have high fleet utilization
because that's key
to making money.
You're going to optimize
the size of your fleet
so that you have high
utilization, low empty miles,
and fast response times.
And so I don't think
that carries over
to the driverless discussion.
Fortunately, the regulators
at the local, state,
and federal level
for driverless cars
have understood
that the only way
we're going to get to this
goal of fully driverless
is to learn on public roads.
So they haven't stepped up
and said you can't do this.
And by the way, that's a big
difference between General
Motors and Google.
Sebastian Thrun and Chris
Urmson and their team,
when they started
their project, they
wanted to learn on public roads.
And so they wondered
if they could do it
in the law in
California said you
needed to have a driver
in the driver's seat.
It didn't say you
needed to touch
the steering wheel, the brake
pedal, or the accelerator.
So they just went
off and did it.
My general counsel at General
Motors would say no way.
You can only test
in a proving ground.
So they had to get
on public roads.
And this is a technology.
Think about it.
You eliminate 90% of the
crashes in the world.
There's 1.3 million
people a year
dying on the world's roadways.
That is epidemic in scale.
Get rid of 90% of that,
that's a million lives a year.
Divide that by 365,
that's 3,000 lives a day.
If we get to this end
goal one day sooner,
we're going to say 3,000 lives.
So I think the biggest risk
is not moving fast enough.
And the regulators
fortunately haven't said stop,
haven't said you can't
learn on public roads and.
We're making good progress.
We need to be open, share
the data, and learn together.
But I think we'll
take that journey,
and we'll get there, Jeremy.
I really do.
JEREMY HYLTON: It reminds
me of another funny story
in the book.
I think from early on with
the Carnegie Mellon team
that they were posting videos
on their blog of testing
the vehicle, stopping.
And someone-- somewhere on
your team a middle manager
saw it and thought, oh, my god.
I can't believe GM
is funding this.
We've got to put an end to it.
LAWRENCE D. BURNS: Yeah,
very, very different cultures.
We had a sad stretch
in the late 80s
and early 90s of too many
fatalities in our plants.
These were our employees.
Maybe they had to do
maintenance on a robot,
and they didn't lock out the
robot and they got in there
and got electrocuted
or something.
So we said enough is enough.
So we went and benchmarked
the best in the world.
Alcoa, Dupont, and we want to
be the benchmark safest company
to work for.
So safety was really ingrained
into everybody at GM.
So when this individual
who reported to me
saw how our Carnegie Mellon
team was testing the vehicles,
he felt it was way outside the
envelope on our safety culture
and felt we needed to
shut down the program.
We worked through that.
Chris Urmson did a good
job with some diplomacy.
But really I can't
overemphasize that safety
has to be the overriding
priority for any organization.
And I so admire what the
Google self-driving car
team has accomplished,
and they've
done it with a tremendous
safety culture.
They've got this group,
we call it the ops group.
And every morning, they
shake down all the cars,
make sure the car is physically
ready to go out on the road,
put their cell phones
in their locker.
They go out, and they're
highly trained people following
standardized processes.
And they really, really
take their job seriously.
Whenever you have-- if you ever
have a chance to be in the area
where they work, you almost feel
like it's the same discipline
you would see in
military operations.
It's that serious, and
it's paid off for us.
Waymo has had one
at-fault crash.
Was a two-mile-per-hour
fender bender.
We've had some others, and
in all those other cases,
it was the other driver--
it was the human driver that
caused it.
JEREMY HYLTON: I've
been curious about what
the limits of unexpected
things you can plan for are.
Thinking to a story from the
Urban Mobility Challenge,
what happens if your
autonomous vehicle pulls
up next to the Jumbotron
and that disables the GPS?
LAWRENCE D. BURNS: This
is one of these moments--
the Carnegie Mellon team had
some challenges along the way.
The first race
was in the desert,
and part of their
development work
they rolled their Hummer,
which was their development
vehicle, over.
And that caused some
problem with sensors,
and we think that's why
it only went seven miles.
In the second race,
lo and behold,
they have the same thing happen.
They had two vehicles
in that race.
The one that really was probably
the best vehicle had a fuel--
or it actually an
electromagnetic interference
since we found out later on--
damaged, and it was causing
strange things with the fuel.
And so the-- lost my train
of thought again, Jeremy.
What was the point?
JEREMY HYLTON: I was
thinking about the-- and then
in the Urban
Mobility Challenge--
LAWRENCE D. BURNS: Yeah.
And then in the actual
DARPA Urban Challenge,
we were the favorite.
We thought we were
going to win this race.
We felt real good
about all of our tests.
And through the
preliminary heats,
they sort it down
to 14 finalists,
and we were in
the pole position.
And that meant we got to
go out on the track first.
And we couldn't get
the GPS to calibrate.
Something just wouldn't lock in.
And everyone's
panicking, and they
go to get another GPS unit.
And it turns out ESPN
was covering the event,
and they had a huge
Jumbotron located right next
to our vehicle.
And the person from the Defense
Advanced Research Projects
Agency, DARPA, who sponsored
it, Tony Tether, said,
turn off the Jumbotron.
As soon as they turned it
off, our GPS calibrated,
and we were back in the race.
So, yes, there are--
those are learning things.
I dedicate this
book to engineers
who make what's possible real.
How many of you here today are
engineers or computer science
or technical backgrounds?
That's really what we do.
And I am an engineer
from the top of my head
to the tips of my toes.
And as long as the principles
of science are followed,
I think an engineer can
accomplish almost anything
if you give them the
right learning cycles.
But who would have
thought we would
have had this interference,
but now we know.
And that's what
this is all about,
learning way out on the
tail of the distribution
on learning cycles.
And that was one of those
great examples of learning.
JEREMY HYLTON: Great
example of what's
going to go wrong in
the real world when we--
LAWRENCE D. BURNS: Yes.
Yes, things will go
wrong in the real world.
Sadly, they go wrong and
kill 40,000 Americans a year
right now.
And I have to be
really candid with you.
Every time I read about
someone going the wrong way
on the interstate and
having a head on killing
four or five people,
it just breaks my heart
because I know the technology
exists to prevent that.
And my daughters are 30
and 27, so I took them
through a driver's training and
it was an absolute nightmare
to see an inexperienced driver.
Next time you do-- go-- drive
through a busy intersection--
you're an experienced driver.
Think of what you're
sorting out, all
of the visual
clutter that's there
and what you really
have to pay attention
to to get through that
intersection safely.
And now you take a 15-year-old
kid who's never done it before.
It's a learning curve, Jeremy.
And we've got to do
better than this.
We absolutely have to do
better than those fatalities.
JEREMY HYLTON: I
did like the way
you can contrast the engineering
cultures in Detroit and Silicon
Valley through the book.
And they each have their
strengths, and I think you--
I'm pretty sympathetic to the
Google software engineering
culture, but you pointed out
how maybe some of the Googlers
needed to come to terms with the
thing Detroit is good at, too.
LAWRENCE D. BURNS: Yeah.
Yeah.
The original title of
the book was "The Race
to Build the Driverless Car."
And Echo, who's our publisher,
and Denise, who's the editor
is here--
Denise you may want
to raise your hand.
But she said maybe you out
to write it about the quest.
And that was really
an important moment
for myself and Chris
Shulgan because suddenly we
realized maybe this isn't
Silicon Valley versus Detroit.
Maybe it's a bigger
story than that.
Early on when I first arrived
as the gray-haired executive
at Google Self-driving
Cars, there
was I would say an
arrogance in the team
about Silicon Valley being able
to handle these great world
challenges at light speed.
And the auto industry had
lost its way on innovation
and really, really was
no longer imaginative.
At the same time when Chris
Urmson and Anthony Levandowski
first went to Detroit looking
for car companies and suppliers
to collaborate
with, they basically
threw them out the door.
Thought they were
irresponsible developing cars
on public roads.
So there is this tension between
the Silicon Valley culture
and the Detroit culture.
Where the story stands now,
where this quest stands now,
its an and.
It's not an or.
I think by hiring John
Krafcik to lead the Waymo,
it was a recognition by
Alphabet's leadership
that they needed somebody
with a lot of car experience
to take this forward
and commercialize it.
And John was really, really
deep in his experience.
And at the same time, I
think Ford and General Motors
realized that they're going to
have to reach out to Silicon
Valley to outsource their
research and development
and autonomous vehicle systems.
So GM acquired
Cruise Automation.
And then Argo AI was
acquired by Ford.
So they've come together.
It's a Silicon
Valley and Detroit
that will lead this forward.
JEREMY HYLTON: Yeah.
Yeah.
Quite fascinating.
I think another thing
that move this story along
was some combination of
visionaries and setting
really audacious goals, these
challenges, both DARPA's
challenges and then I
guess Larry and Sergei
setting challenges
with Sebastian
through and in others.
What can you make happen here?
LAWRENCE D. BURNS: It's a
great management principles,
setting stretch goals.
When you're the person who has
to reach this stretch goal,
sometimes it can be a
little bit frightening.
But think about it this way.
You could say you're--
you want to accomplish
something on a scale of 10,
and you can set your goal
at six and get to seven
and feel good about it.
Or you could have set your
goal at nine and get to eight
and not get there.
You'd rather be at
eight than seven.
So stretch goal is an
important principle.
The Defense Advanced Research
Projects Agency, DARPA,
set stretch goals for the Desert
Challenge of which are two,
and then the goal for the
Urban Challenge with 60
miles in the city setting
with no one in the car,
no remote control,
obey all traffic laws,
get it done in six hours.
And nobody thought
it could be done.
So the DARPA challenge ends.
Everybody's feeling
great about it.
Tony Tether, the head of DARPA,
says mission accomplished.
You guys have proven
this can be done.
It's up to the commercial
sector to run with it.
And we all thought people
would be falling all
over themselves wanting to
take the next step to make
it commercial, and
nothing happened.
Caterpillar reached
out and started
doing some work for
mining applications,
but we wanted to change the
whole world of automobiles.
Larry and Sergei were the only
two leaders that stepped up.
Larry and Sergei, they
were at that race.
They had a passion
for this subject.
And Larry had a
great conversation
with Sebastian Thrun
and said Sebastian
told Larry we can't do this.
We shouldn't do it.
Sebastian told Larry, I'm
the best in this field.
I know what I'm talking about.
We shouldn't get into it.
And Larry said I have
to tell Eric and Sergei
a real reason why we can do it.
So he sends Sebastian
back the third time,
and finally Sebastian came
said, well, maybe we can.
And then they set
these stretch goals.
Think about this as
a form of leadership.
Larry wanted it to go on
every road in California.
So they negotiated that they
would pick 10 100-mile routes.
And you know who
laid out the routes?
Larry and Sergei.
And they put a bonus
in place for the team
to get this done in two years.
So Sebastian negotiates
another goal,
100,000 miles on public roads
because they want at least
get a little bit of payment.
This is really
impressive leadership.
And then they stuck with the
team, and the team got it done.
So there's a
management lesson here.
You have to set it
far enough out where
it's really hard to get
there but not so far out
that it's impossible.
And they've subsequently put
additional goals on the Waymo
team that they're
working really,
really hard on right now
in Chandler, Arizona,
tied to do people like
riding in these cars?
Can you do it safely?
Is a business here?
All of that stuff but
it's really a good lesson
in the management.
JEREMY HYLTON: I
guess Tony at DARPA
had the most challenging one.
He really had to
stick to his guns
because after the first Urban
Challenge-- or the first Desert
Challenge was supposed to be
150 miles, and the best car did,
what seven miles.
LAWRENCE D. BURNS:
Came in seven miles
and he had all those media
stacked up at the finish line,
and nobody got there.
So Tony goes to the finish line,
and he says I got great news.
The next race-- and he's--
is on this date and the
prize is $2 million.
He really pivoted well.
JEREMY HYLTON: That's got guts.
LAWRENCE D. BURNS:
But this is a lot
of money for these young
teams competing for it.
JEREMY HYLTON: Yeah.
I thought that
was a great story.
Stick with this approach.
I was also curious--
like the engineering cultures
are coming to appreciate the--
what they have to
offer each other.
But you also I think made a
point, at least in Detroit,
there's actually a hierarchy
of engineering teams.
So the parts manufacturers and
some of the parts manufacturers
are as big as the auto companies
that sell the brand name.
And so I wonder what
kind of hierarchy
are we going to
see in the future?
Is Uber the brand we're going
to know or Lyft or Waymo?
Is it going to be Toyota.
Is there going to be a lot
of competition about that?
LAWRENCE D. BURNS: Yes.
There's going to be competition.
First of all, there's
a lot of different use
cases for these brands.
There's the use case of
Ubers, Lyfts without drivers.
There's the use case of you
basically leasing an autonomous
vehicle and having a
subscription service so
that you're controlling it.
So think about that.
You say I want one of
these for 12 months,
and I'm going to subscribe
for 30,000 miles.
It takes you to
work, drops you off.
You then dispatch it to
go pick up your spouse,
take him or her to
work, drop them off,
and your spouse dispatches it
to go pick up your kid at school
for soccer practice and
then mother-in-law for Meals
on Wheels.
So you may use this one
dedicated vehicle to the point
where you don't need
that second or third car,
but you're still going to have
that control that you have.
So you've got that use case.
Don't forget goods movement.
Over the road trucking--
the shortage of truck
drivers or truck drivers, $0.64
a mile in benefits and wages.
And it's a tedious job.
It takes people away
from their homes,
so there's real value
to be created there.
And then finally, that
last mile of delivery.
My goodness, I work
out of my home office.
I've had two times
were the UPS and FedEx
truck were in my driveway
at the same time.
I came home from
golfing two weeks ago,
I had nine boxes on my porch.
My wife has been busy.
She's a her stylist.
She really likes to get all
this stuff over the internet,
but that last mile, if
you can get the driver out
of the local delivery system,
whether it's with drones or you
name it.
So a wide range of use cases.
How are you going to
brand that is important.
What are the experiences
you're going to deliver?
It's not just going
from point A to point B
and getting there safely.
It's does it pick me up
at my precise location,
drop me off precisely,
is the ride so nice
that when I get
out of the vehicle,
I feel better than
when I got in to it?
Can I get to more places
with brand A versus brand B?
That's going to be a
basis of competition.
But the one place
I think you want
to be beyond anything else
in this future ecosystem
is to have the world's best
driver because the world's best
driver can play on every
one of those use cases.
And it's typically more
than half the cost per mile
that we incur today.
So that's a big opportunity.
Now does this play out in a
Microsoft kind of a business
model or an Intel
Inside business
model or an arm business model?
Those decisions
haven't been made yet.
There's still a lot of work to
do before you start scaling.
I think the experience
as it get branded.
I personally think
the car companies
are going to have
a tough time saying
Chevrolet is the right brand
for a mobility service.
I think that's going to
be a bit of a stretch.
So I think you're going to
see some rebranding going on.
It's going to be fun.
JEREMY HYLTON: Yeah.
All right.
It's been great talking to you.
I think I have to let everyone
else ask some questions.
LAWRENCE D. BURNS:
Well, thank you.
Thank you.
Thank you for reading the book.
Your questions were excellent.
And certainly when
you're an author,
you love it when someone
would give you some
of your time over the weekend.
It's really nice, Jeremy,
that you did that.
JEREMY HYLTON: Yeah.
It was great fun to read.
Great stories.
LAWRENCE D. BURNS: Just
one thing for the Q&A.
I lost my hearing 20 years ago.
I hear with cochlear implants,
and it's same technology
as autonomous cars.
Its batteries and sensors and
software and all of that stuff.
I think I'll hear you fine,
but if not, Jeremy will help me
with the questions.
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: Hey, Larry, thanks
for coming to talk to us.
I have a three-year-old at home,
and I think about in 13 years,
he's going to get
his driver's license.
What are the odds
that he's going
to get his driver's license?
LAWRENCE D. BURNS: I think
the odds are pretty low.
There's a lot of people who
are enthusiastic about driving,
and 100 years ago, there
were a lot of people
enthusiastic about horses.
And--
[LAUGHING]
They're still horse racing.
They're still equestrian-- the
important message right now
is not that we're going
to say you can't drive,
but for a lot of
people, we're going
to say you're going to get
the accessibility, mobility
benefits of owning and operating
a car and not have to drive.
So your child is going to
be able to make a choice
by the time they're 15 or 16.
There's a lot of negatives
with owning and operating
a car beyond the safety risk.
Having to stop to buy gas,
having to find parking,
and having to get
your car maintained,
having to shop for
it, have it insured
and finance it and you
put all that together
and you say, man,
that's a real hassle.
And this industry's
existed for a century
assuming you're willing to do
that and pay $35,000 for a car.
So I think that world's
going to change quite a bit.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
LAWRENCE D. BURNS: Thank you.
Over here.
AUDIENCE: So I actually
have two questions.
The first one is a big
downside of electric vehicles
has always been
distance per charge.
What about taking
a trip in the world
that you were describing here?
How would I go from New
York City to Buffalo
to get some Buffalo
wings for the weekend?
How does that play
into what you're
talking about, which is more
daily travel, commuting,
et cetera.
LAWRENCE D. BURNS: Yeah.
Yeah.
That's an exciting question.
The range of the batteries
has increased significantly.
The Chevrolet Bolt, for example,
has about a 230-mile range.
So we think the
battery is sufficient
for the everyday community
usage in this shared model.
Going between
communities, you may
have like a range extender that
you could associate with this,
almost like a pod that
snaps on the back that's
extra battery just when you
need to make that trip that
can extend your range and
extend your power to do that.
I wouldn't totally rule
out hydrogen or fuel cells.
I wish I never uttered the word
fuel cell because this is just
hydrogen battery.
It's another kind of a battery.
But that's its real advantage
is you can fill up with hydrogen
and have significant range.
I do think when
the market's there,
we're going to have
the solutions in place
to get you from Buffalo
to New York City
if that's where you want to go.
One way ticket to
Buffalo though.
AUDIENCE: That's right.
We can plug it in
when we get there.
So we saw in the late
90s, early 2000s with EV1,
for example, as you mentioned
the effect of the oil and gas
lobbies and their
effect on the saturation
of the electric vehicle as a
whole in the United States.
Has that changed at all?
Are we at a point where we're
ready to see gas and oil
cars off the road?
Or are we still fighting
that same battle?
LAWRENCE D. BURNS:
I certainly can
see a pathway to not
need oil any longer
in the transportation sector.
I hesitate a bit.
Diesel is a really good way
to move 80,000-pounds loads,
so there may be some
applications there.
But I think for about 80% of
the oil, we can get off of that.
Will we?
The thing that keeps me up
at night, quite honestly, I
think what's going
to gate all of this
are those very
powerful voices that
have a vested interest in the
130-year-old automobile roadway
transportation system.
The easiest thing to do in
Washington DC is say no,
and these companies who have
something to lose from this
are very good at
knowing how to say no.
So that does concern
me, but technologically
I think we're there.
I think in terms of
value proposition
for all of us living our
everyday lives, I think where
their.
Business model,
investors wanting
to put the money
in this new future
rather than where we've
been, I think we're there.
Now it's just a matter of
almost like the baseball movie
"Field of Dreams," if I
build it, they will come.
And that's why I'm so proud to
be part of Waymo as an advisor
because that's what they're
doing in Chandler as they're
proving this thing out.
AUDIENCE: Cool.
Thank you very much.
LAWRENCE D. BURNS: Thank you.
Thank you.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
You mentioned that
you view this market
as being very competitive,
and I was just
wondering how you
think about network
effects of like Uber and Lyft.
Basically their
entire business model
is just if you have
all the drivers,
then you have all
the passengers,
and you can be a monopoly.
I guess how do you think
about what the market will
look like whether you--
transportation is
centralizing and what
regulatory other options--
LAWRENCE D. BURNS: Very
important questions.
And one of the
interesting part--
results from the work
I do the Columbia,
not only did we get this
$0.20-per-mile opportunity
identified, it turns out scale
economies are reached at about
10% of the miles
driven in a community.
What I mean by that is if I
had a shared fleet that I was
running in Ann Arbor and
I had 10% market share
then I went to 11%, my cost per
mile wasn't going down anymore.
That suggests that
you don't need
to have the entire market in
order to have scale and be
competitive.
With that said, there's
definitely network effects,
so there's definitely
scaling effects.
There's learning effects.
I talk about having the
world's best driver.
One of the best
ways to do that is
to be learning from more
and more and more vehicles
on the road every day.
And when-- the beauty
of a driverless car
is when I learn
something from one car,
I can put it in all the other
cars and make all of them
safer.
When I learn something as
a human driver about how
to do something better,
I have no mechanism
for transferring that
to other human drivers.
So these things
are real important,
and I think they're going
to have to be watched.
Certainly not a reason
not to go forward
but they're going to have
to be managed for sure.
Over here.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Hi.
I'm very excited
about driverless cars,
and certainly there's
tremendous future.
There's one thing that
worries me about--
its impact on freedom--
because car was the
greatest vehicle
for freedom and opportunity.
Ability to go someplace is
a great boon for humans.
But now the way the driverless
cars are being actual
designed and implemented means
we depend on cloud services
and on provider
of cloud services
desire to enable my trip.
Google decides not
to map certain area,
the cars will not
go to that area.
Google or better yet
the government decides
that certain event is
not good, they can easily
make cars not go to that event.
And this is because
we have no other way
of doing things other than
through the cloud service.
We will not really own anything
even if we buy the car.
LAWRENCE D. BURNS: Yeah.
First of all, the
title of my book
is "Autonomy" because I
believe this future is
going to bring more freedom.
There's a lot of
people today that
can't benefit from owning
and operating an automobile.
They're too young to drive it.
They're too old.
They're not capable
physically to do it.
They can't afford it.
Whatever it might be.
So we really think were
going to bring more freedom
to a lot more people with this.
If the concern that you
raise, which is really
my area of expertise, if
you're concerned about that,
I'd encourage you to go
out and start working on it
because we want this to be an
enabler of much greater freedom
rather than a
constraint or a freedom.
I think when you look at the
100-year history of the auto
industry, a lot of that stuff
was playing out as well.
Where were you going
to build the road,
and we're going to
build a parking lot?
And who pays for the
roads and all of that?
And I think we have
created an extensive amount
of uneven access and inequality
in our mobility systems.
I live north of Detroit, and
our neighborhoods in Detroit
still have a lot of poverty.
And these people can't break
out of the cycle of poverty
because we don't have
any transportation
alternatives other than a car.
And the car insurance
is off the chart.
It's expensive.
So all of this has to be
managed and talked about.
And I'd encourage the
dialogue to continue.
I think great observation.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Hey.
I was wondering if you thought
that the influx of autonomous
vehicles in cities will
result in cities becoming
more multimodal, more walkable,
more bikable, more mass
transit with first, last mile
or if you thought it would just
increase car dependence,
increase the widening of roads,
et cetera.
LAWRENCE D. BURNS: I think
it's going to be the former.
There's three parking
spaces dedicated
to every car in
the United States,
and there's 250 million cars.
So that's a lot of
parking, and that parking
constrains densification.
I do want to make
a point though.
Only 26% of Americans
live in cities.
Fifty-three percent of
Americans live in suburbs.
And that parking issue is
even more severe there.
I'm on the board of a
real estate development
company in Florida, and
we had a parcel of land
that we were developing along
I-75 south of Tampa, St.
Petersburg.
And they ended up putting
a Walmart on that site.
But the amount of
land for parking
was twice the amount of
land for the building.
And this is nuts.
And so I think this
is an opportunity
to really drive densification.
And secondly the vehicles
are dramatically better
at detecting pedestrians,
detecting bicyclists,
and taking a lot of the
risk out of the system
for vulnerable roadway users.
I sometimes talk about
this con-- for the concept
of the secondhand smoke.
I like to talk about
secondhand physics.
For some reason, there's a
belief that somebody can drive
a 5,000-pound Cadillac
Escalade on one of the streets
in Manhattan and go 45
miles an hour, and it's--
that's second hand physics.
It's just kinetic energy.
So we've got to work through it.
But I'm in the
camp where I think
we're going to make
cities more livable,
but very importantly,
I think we're going
to improve suburbs a lot, too.
AUDIENCE: So the whole
driverless car thing seems--
reminds me a lot of the
internet in the 1980s, 1990s
LAWRENCE D. BURNS: It does.
AUDIENCE: A lot of
innovation, exciting things.
One of the things that happened
after that time in the internet
is we discovered there's a
lot of malefactors out there.
And one of the things that
I haven't heard anyone
in this industry really
talking about too much
is how do you defend and
make secure your driverless
car not only against the kind
of attacks that are already
taking place against
automated but driver-full cars
but against jamming or other
kinds of attacks on the sensors
and things like that, which
nobody's doing that now.
It's wonderful.
Everybody's cooperating mostly,
but that doesn't last forever.
LAWRENCE D. BURNS: Yeah.
Yeah.
The whole cyber security area,
again, is not my expertise.
I talk to people who
understand it better than I do.
And we've got a lot of
people working on that hard.
It's not an issue that's
unique to driverless cars.
It also exists in
human-driven cars.
Our current curves are very
vulnerable to being hacked.
It's part of the
other systems we
use in our daily
lives, the airline
system and other things.
And so I share the
concern, but not to--
and I'm not implying
you're suggesting this--
but not to the
point where it says
we shouldn't be pushing
this opportunity to it's
full extent.
I believe the way to go
at this is to think big.
And certainly Google
Self-driving Cars
and Google and
Alphabet are thinking
very big in this space.
Start small-- 13 Priuses
get out and start learning
on public roads, learn fast.
We've been learning fast
now for almost a decade,
and it's been
extraordinary insights.
And then scale smart.
I don't think
anyone's going to want
to scale a system that
has the vulnerabilities
that you're concerned with.
We're going to have to
have solutions to that.
Should that be the
first problem to fix?
I don't know.
I don't think solving snowstorms
on Loveland Pass at night time
was the first thing to
work on on driverless cars.
We may never solve that one.
But I think we got to
get out there and learn.
So one more question.
JEREMY HYLTON:
One more question.
LAWRENCE D. BURNS:
One more please.
AUDIENCE: So just where does
it start in a big way I mean?
Of course, it makes sense
to focus on the desired end
state of changing the car
experience for Americans.
But does it actually start
in some more limited domain?
I don't know,
long-haul trucking or--
LAWRENCE D. BURNS: Yes, it does.
AUDIENCE: Enthusiasts,
early adopters,
or city centers where
there's restricted access
for other kind of
vehicles or what?
LAWRENCE D. BURNS: I
think those use cases are
very exciting places to start--
gated communities, campuses,
low-speed applications.
The interesting thing about
over-the-road trucking
is not all freeway links
are created the same.
Some are flat, straight, nice
weather, low-traffic density,
much easier to get
started with his business
than some of the curvier
higher-traffic areas.
So it's not going to be just
we suddenly take and deploy it
on a large scale in a
major metropolitan area.
I think you're going to see a
whole bunch of these smaller
plays done as we work hard.
Again, no one's saying we're
ready to commercialize this
at scale.
What we are saying is we believe
the technology is reaching
a point where there's
commercial-- consumer value
to be had.
And I think with any startup,
you want to get to that point.
You want to get real customers.
You want to get real
money coming in.
That's what we're doing
the business to do.
But I think these opportunities
you talk about are there.
JEREMY HYLTON: All right, great.
Thanks so much.
LAWRENCE D. BURNS:
Thanks everybody.
I really appreciate it.
[APPLAUSE]